you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast on the wonderful and very
current topic towards standardized
workflows a focus on microbiome insights
this webinar will be presented by dr.
Rita Colwell University professor at the
University of Maryland at College Park
and president of Cosmos ID incorporated
and dr. Christiane Hunnish global head
of business intelligence and development
Eppendorf AG hi I'm Christie jewel of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation additionally we have three
pools today and we thank you in advance
for your participation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by using the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and the
software is continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
now I'd like to introduce today's
presenters dr. Rita Colwell is a
distinguished University professor at
the University of Maryland at College
Park and president of cosmos idea
incorporated her interests are focused
on global infectious diseases water and
health she has authored or co-authored
19 books and more than 800 scientific
publications dr. Colville developed an
international network to address
emerging infectious diseases and water
issues including safe drinking water for
both the developed and developing world
in collaboration with safe water network
headquartered in New York City dr.
Christian honish is the head of global
business intelligence at Epidaurus and
has over 15 years of experience
developing assays and cutting-edge
technology for life science applications
with a focus on genomics and
microbiology prior to her position at
Epidaurus Hamburg Germany dr. harnosh
was director of microbiology markets at
Illumina in San Diego and director of
infectious disease research at Roche
molecular diagnostics San Francisco for
complete biographies on their speakers
please visit the biography Club at the
top of your screen now let's get started
dr. Cole well and dr. harness the stage
is yours
yeah thank you very much for the
introduction and welcome to this webinar
discussing the benefits of standardized
workflows and the data analysis and
microbiome research so the work of
microbiome research is an era which is
no longer on strictly by microbiologist
but by cross-functional fields of
expertise including computer science
oncology immunology forensics
agriculture and many more areas and
which is which as a sepsis Association
sorry with the composition and function
of microbes are revealed so we see an
explosion of microbiome science in front
of us and the app clearly makes a
difference and provided the basis for
growing sample throughput and cancer
numbers and started to metaphor
meaningful Association studies and for
the acceptance of research in
peer-reviewed journals and this is the
time where you want to use the term the
same sample preparation as your kale
else like the laboratory which retails
running and get an easy entry into
accepted protocols and automated sample
preparation and the end of this
introduction we are taking a few steps
further and beyond India's and briefly
look at how the scientific community
turns outcomes of microbiome Association
studies into applications for
influencing the microbiome as well
so micros has populated and dominated
and shaped our planet and since as you
can see from this diverse pictures the
health of our planets environment and
its inhabitants are absolutely dependent
on the microbial partners in all sorts
of areas microbiome purify the water as
you will hear later on from Vita and
naturally controlling the flux of
nutrients that can regulate the
development of stable ecosystems the
human microbiome has become a total of
multi-omics research studies and to find
out whether changes in the microbiome
are the cause of consequence any of many
human diseases and conditions and beyond
the gut the human microbiome likely
affects all organs through the immune
system circulatory and the nervous
system including communicating with our
brains and protects our behavior and
cognitive recognition in addition to
that and their studies in the
environment through oil drilling and
bioproducts as well
so and yes make meet with a genomic
studies and successful and
identification they facilitate the
editing and identification and taxonomic
diversity of microbiota and the number
of publications not limited to NGS in
this slide but the includes also
metabolomics proteomics and culture and
I expect exponentially growing we live
in an era where microbiome insights make
a clear difference and when microbiome
has become a familiar subject even to
the general public and we hear that in
the media so a multitude of consortia on
a regional and global scale have been
formed and sample numbers as I mentioned
before testily are increasing and the
standardization of work drugs becomes us
an integral part of data embarrassed
comparability across the research
community
so if we look at standardized workflows
there are some key benefits and which
are decreasing the margin of human error
in the laboratory optimizing automated
sample processing better accuracy and
quality of life results comparability of
results at the global sphere especially
when you look at these consortia cross
reduction of retesting cost reduction
and sorry of retesting efficient
training of your workflows and
alleviation it is alleviating issues of
liquid handling stress
so I would like to take you through an
example now that shows where a
standardized workflow makes the
difference for data comparability
so the study is a longtime exploration
of the response of the human gut
microbiome response to different immune
genes being knocked out each of the
colors in this chart represents a
difference knock out and the spheres
which are circles here I'm sure the
other diversity of the gut microbiome of
the mice within the different groups
which I'm explaining this and why have
animals from three mouth vendors show up
is distinct clusters on the right hand
side in green orange and purple mixtures
of the stool of these three mice were
used
inoculate to knock out animals in this
study so knockout mice were initially
treated with antibiotics to wipe out
their gut microbiome and that's shown on
the left hand side in the in the blue
sphere and whereas mice which used were
use as controls pre antibiotics are
shown in the blanks where the middle
part shows the study outcome overall
honor on a timescale after the treatment
after after the microphone was swiped
out and after the treatment with the
artificial stool what I would like to
draw your attention to though is the
bottom red sphere and because overall
samples were processed using automated
liquid handling and controls were
included into each place and used as a
part of the automated standardized
process they have the tightly and and
does facilitate and inform the
underlying basis for the rest of the
samples and the accuracy of the
has wowed
so next I would like from this
introduction go into a little bit of the
detail dive into the overworks nose in
them in microbiome analysis so
everything starts with a sample
collection a specimen collection and
those can come out of different sample
types like stool like skin and these
samples need to be stored and ideally
managed and in the ideal world use using
a digitalized system for managing those
gamut of samples which pile up in
different laboratories the middle part
the dinner to workflows when are
facilitating analysis through sample
processing for genomic screening
supported by NGS in the top middle one
name and traffic processing for
metabolomics and proteome studies which
are majorly supported nowadays to mass
spectrometry analysis and lastly
consortium based culture on my Krug
isolation is facilitated through
dilution and culture all the way to the
production scale and harvesting and
that's the follow-up stage once we know
what's in the microbiome sample and we
would like to culture individual cells
or we want in the end like to change and
affect the microbiome
stepping a little deeper before I do
that actually the so I step a little
deep I would like to get some of your
feedback on on the workflows and ask you
to interact which of the steps of the
microbiome workflow is most relevant to
you sample storage next-generation
sequencing
mass spectrometry or cell culture
I'll give you some time to answer this
question so again we would be very
interested to learning which step of the
microbiome workflow is the most relevant
to your sample storage next-gen
sequencing mass spectrometry or cell
culture
you
we see some answers coming sport and we
are getting we are getting some answers
please continue to give us your feedback
again which of the steps which step of
the microbiome workflow is most relevant
to you
we still see answers coming through
okay after getting all your feedback
you
you
you
okay I think we we are ending the pool
has finished to change in terms of the
numbers here
you
here got a clear answer now so most of
you seem to be interested in
next-generation sequencing and we also
see some interest in cell culture
actually which is something I'm going to
tap in a B at the end of my presentation
okay following your answers as well and
let's seem to take a deeper dive into
the NGS method so NGS microbiome screens
are based on three major workflows which
is targeted sequencing 16s or ids/ips
sequencing shotgun metagenomic and meta
transcriptomics the workshop consists of
sample extraction and the preparation
which is supported by different vendors
and kissed by different vendors and then
NGS with different platform technologies
and data analysis which you will hear in
depth from Rita Rita later on the
majority of these are supported and free
programs on the Eppendorf platform when
it comes to sample extraction and
libraries
baseness so for the library preparation
and the extraction of the sample the
ethanol platform supports different
throughput needs a 96 samples all the
way down to 24 and complex applications
like sample preparation can also now be
run on a smaller device which you see on
the right hand side
this is facilitated through smart
accessories on the instrument using the
versions of vertical deck spaces smart
usage of dedicated deck space and and
the use between space and smart
accessories
you
so let us not take steps from the MGF
screen into turning out comes from these
association studies into deeper dive by
isolating individual microbes and
ultimately modifying the microbe looking
at workflows which supportive our
culture of single microbes and/or
consortium cultures on a small scale or
all the way to production scale and then
the harvesting of that with this as we
saw some interest on that parts of the
workflow as well let us ask the next
poll question and ask for your
participation again which is your main
pain point do you microbiome experiments
the sample collection the sample
preparation the sample extraction NGS
library preparation or data analysis
so I would like to ask you to now take
your vote again on the question which
often which is your main pain points
during microbiome experiment sample
collection sample preparation sample
extraction NGS library preparation or
data analysis
and it looks really interesting are we
getting a shift of the blood smell
again which is your main pain point
during microbiome experiments sample
collection sample preparation
some extraction NGOs library preparation
or data analysis
and is shifting again so first more
words we had really under data analysis
site but there seems to be pain points
also in sample extraction and entire
library preparation which is very very
valuable to note
and points to that the standardization
of the workflow seems to be very very
important
again you still have time to vote on
these
now we have about 40% on the world
preparation size of the sample including
extraction and preparation and we have
about the same percentage on the data
analysis
which we hopefully address in this
webinar
I think we coming to an end of the
voting here
and the final the final outcome is
really that we have about 40% of the
participants here who have pain points
during the whole sample generation type
of standardization of the workflow is
really important and what if you send on
the data analysis where we will learn
more from Rita later on
and with this as my last point I would
like to make one last comment in terms
of another piece of support for
standardized workflows I would like to
mention connectivity and which Eppendorf
equipment offers of the workflow
connecting devices for data capture and
ultimately potential monitoring and with
that I would like to thank you very much
for your attention on this part of the
presentation and I'm happy to hand over
and welcome with the professor dr.
Ritter : now out of the presentation
thank you very much crystianna's was
very helpful as a introduction to what I
will be discussing this morning first of
all a good morning to those of us in the
u.s. good afternoon
those in Europe and to participate
participants in Asia good evening what
I'd like to talk about is the fact that
we have focused really on how to
standardize the micro biome analysis
process yes as you've just heard your
own interest are very much concerned
with the sample preparation and data
analysis but let me just say that we are
working really hard at Carlos ID to
standardize every step of the process
for example metagenomics is very
vulnerable to sample contamination and
we also have to be aware of
compositional bias and therefore
standardize workflow is really critical
there are a variety of eresources than
that the number in the sample can be
very small and certainly sample
preparation for sequencing is a major
issue what I'd like to do is point out
that on the background I think for
understanding the microbiome is really
rooted in fundamental microbiology and
let me give just a bit of a historical
perspective for example I really we've
gone through a series of stages over the
last almost 50 years of way back in the
60s we were concerned about phenotype it
wasn't just entirely culture and at that
time I wrote several computer programs
that provided a numerical basis for our
analysis which we now follow really
except we use DNA base composition we go
to the steps of everything from being
excited about understanding the
composition by bases of nucleic acid all
the way through highly sensitive
techniques for detection including
polymerase chain reaction or PCR who are
now really in the generation of
metagenomics what's really important is
that we're focusing on disease
identification of disease agents in
understanding infections and I think
waterborne diseases which is a personal
interest of the last 40 years the
waterborne diseases are really global
and they continue to the present cholera
for example there are over 1 and a half
billion cases every year and over a
million sometimes up to 2 million deaths
from the disease
so understanding a infectious disease is
really critical the organism is a simple
bacterium I can easily be cultured but
the effects are devastating in terms of
loss of fluid sodium potassium imbalance
and dehydration which can lead to death
we made a very early discovery that the
bacterium is naturally occurring in the
environment and its associated its host
our plankton as Oh plankton
in fact you could say that this is a
disease that is transmitted by the
microorganisms association with plankton
in the environment I work in Bangladesh
over the last 40 or 50 years by a
variety of investigators in my own team
included found that in fact we could
relate the outbreaks of the disease to
immediate environmental parameters the
fact is that villagers in the
environment drink water directly from
streams where it's used at the same time
for bathing and unfortunately also as a
latrine what
discoveries we made very early on was
that we could only culture a small
proportion of the bacteria that are
present if you use the direct
fluorescent antibody which is shadowed
in in green and the yellow is culture
and by means of techniques we were able
to show that so tell me by electron
microscopy if you look at the bottom
left actively growing cells in quadrant
a cells after several weeks in a low
temperature environment and then
eventually after several months in
quadrant D of the bacteria rounded up
and look like spores but they don't form
spores the important point is that by
using a very special technique of uptake
of radio wave substrates etc those cells
in Quadrant II are not dead they're very
much a lot but not culturable
now in by the - we've been able to show
that indeed the bacteria are in the
environment constantly that part of the
natural flora some of the Vibrio
cholerae - luminescent and some are
nitrogen fixers and almost every one
that we've tested have been able to
break down chitin which is the the
backbone of the host the zooplankton but
it's certainly within the population
that I mean we're able to show that
person-to-person transmission is the
source of the bacterium but the
bacterium is really derived from the
environment another interesting
observation is that we're able to take
satellite sensors and measure sea
surface temperature and we're able to to
correlate those environmental parameters
chlorophyll sea surface temperature with
the outbreaks environment ich that is
the numbers of patients that are being
treated in the lower regions and the
villages of Bangladesh that led us then
to build some very specific models which
we've been able to utilize very
effectively to
the outbreaks of Cholera for example
Katie after the 2015 hurricane and we're
doing some real-time prediction for
Yemen and that I think has turned out to
be extremely exciting because we are now
working with the British aid agency the
differed Organization and the British
meteorological organization along with
NASA in the European satellites to
predict when we're in high-risk portions
of the country and the British aid
agency is now able to locate physicians
and supplies to deal with cholera very
effectively and as a result there were
millions of cases in 2017 of cholera in
Yemen but by this teamwork using
satellite sensing model prediction
locating the physicians we were able to
reduce the numbers of cholera cases
many-fold to perhaps only a 20% or 30%
in most of the cases that had occurred
in the previous year so now let's turn
to the role of the microbiome in health
and disease because this is all
connected and let me show you as I
proceed in the discussion how this is so
the microbiome as we have been able to
determine in recent years plays a very
very important role especially in the
gut in a synthesis of vitamins and in
the control of fat and carbohydrate
metabolism and certainly a barrier
against colonization of pathogens such
as C difficile now that that's a good
side the dark side of the microbiome is
that it's implicated very very broadly
in a variety of diseases neurological
neurodegenerative disorders like
Alzheimer's bipolar disorder but very
directly in dentistry with dental
cavities skin diseases and
metabolic disorders and intestinal
diseases such as ultratip colitis
Crohn's disease and irritable bowel
syndrome so there's a good side and a
dark side and I think what's important
is to understand the interaction of the
environment which includes for the
individual lifestyle effect of pollution
and the water the food climate change
certainly as well as the built
environment but the microbiome in the
human host I have this very very
intricate and intimate interaction with
food ingestion and then understanding
what transpires in the gut so the
microbiome composition is in a healthy
state is a composition that we're
beginning to understand and when it goes
into a dysbiotic state we're now
beginning to be able to detect the clues
that demonstrate the change to a disease
state and that it also allows us targets
for therapy in treatment understanding
the host in the microbiome at a systems
level is as you all I think who are
working with the microbiome is very
complex there are the many host
regulation and functions and then the
microbiome interactions and then being
able to connect these very complicated
systems I think is where we are now
moving in understanding microbiome now
the next generation sequencing plays a
critical role because it provides a very
sensitive and a very accurate way of
identifying the participants in the
consortium but also their functions it
is critical to be able to identify to
the strain we've have some techniques
that allow us to understand family genus
maybe a few species but now the next
generation of sequence
in bioinformatics we can get to the
strain in a substrate level why is this
important
obviously for industry it's very
important lactobacillus KCI strain one
is involved in producing cheese another
strain is used to produce Chardonnay and
wine it drove by many people and then
another strain indeed a third string is
used to produce yogurt but for the
physician the important point is that a
different strain of e.coli one strain in
the gut is helpful in producing vitamins
in protecting against other pathogens
but a strain of e.coli o157 h7 ends up
with hemorrhagic and rightis and can be
lethal
particularly for a very young and the
very old now standardizing the
microbiome research is what we at cosmos
ID have been doing very energetically
and in a very consistent way over the
last several years we concerned
ourselves with experimental design which
I mentioned briefly in the beginning
because the power of your analysis
depends on how you designed your
experiments the size of the sample and
certainly the hypothesis that you're
testing and being able to carry out the
appropriate analysis of the data is what
makes the microbiome so powerful and so
we have to understand that best
practices are critical sample
contamination for example we now know
that reagents that are used will
occasionally carry contaminants and
we're able to develop actually a little
library of expected or frequently
encountered contaminants from reagents
there's also a compositional bias that
comes
from not if you don't standardized the
workflow then you may have higher lower
concentrations depending on how the
sample is treated and so we have to
focus on sources of error
we're ensuring that the number of
samples we engage in the analysis is
sufficient and being able to avoid
contamination either from reagents or
from the the technician doing the
handling of the sampling atom databases
are really critical very critical if
they're not complete if they're
inaccurate if they have a lot of
contaminants and then being able to
determine accurate identification that
is eliminating false positives false
negatives and being able to have
accurate classifications really critical
so standardization and compliance are as
I say factors that we have focused on
ensuring that we have negative template
control positive controls spiking in to
be able to essay the validity of our
results and then maintaining good
laboratory practice our laboratory
because CLIA certified and we follow all
of the tip of practices for privacy
security standardization etc so the next
generation of sequencing workflow so
microbiome research are really critical
the 16s approach coupled with 18s in
some cases is is has been used widely
but it does not provide the kind of
accuracy and also the ability to deal
with all of the microorganisms in a
system by combining 16s and 18s one can
come up with a sampling of the bacteria
and the eukaryotes but it is not to the
species level what we have developed is
shotgun hole meta genome sequencing
which means taking a sample extracting
the DNA any sequencer it's agnostic the
approach we use of a sequence reads that
are masked with a database which
provides us then with accurate
identification because we have an
extensive 160,000 curated genomes in the
library this allows us to identify all
of the microorganisms bacteria viruses
fungus protests including parasites and
by again another match to a very
extensive database we can characterize
the presence of antibiotic resistance
genes pathogenicity coding genes
metabolic processes and that gives us
accurate identification including
pathogen identification so let's just
compare 16s output with shotgun
sequencing 16s gives you may be down to
species whereas the shotgun sequencing
gives us the whole community very
important is that the cost although it
is low for 16s we now are working really
hard and getting very close to having
sample cost for whole genome sequencing
very close to of 16s in fact for a
sequence of a stool sample we're now
able to do this under $100 and that is
to do the entire sample analysis and to
be able to identify right down to sub
species in strain for example 16s cannot
give you antibiotic resistance or
virulence factors plasmids presence of
plasmids and presence of bacteria
Pasha's whereas the shotgun sequencing
can do that so now let's look at some of
the analytics that we've been able to
provide and carry out in the microbiome
analysis strain resolution that I keep
mentoring mentioning is real
really very important but it's powered
by the fact that we have highly curated
databases the world's largest and most
comprehensive database and we spent the
last 10 years really curating public
proprietary and our own data sequences
databases and now actually it says
150,000 over close to 160,000 now
genomes which include bacterial viral
fungal and protest genomes commensals
pathogens environmental microorganisms
by an identification to strain level the
other thing that we're now moving into
is machine learning
for industry level of sensitivity and
precision but also to link metadata that
is the intensity of infections with the
presence of the microorganisms the kind
of clinical information that wouldn't
gets for patients and being able to read
relate this to the microbiome but also
in a variety of other areas not just
medicine but also environmental at
cosmetics food safety etc now the
accuracy has been benchmarked if we are
able to identify it you'll note in the
colored portion that in house we've been
able to compare with a comprehensive
benchmarking publication that is listed
in the lower left but if you'll notice
in the upper right it is only the cosmos
ID which is able to identify right down
to two strain species and strain are we
done are competing in a variety of of
challenges and one of which was
organized by Jensen a company of Johnson
& Johnson we received the highest score
and strain level my cobra profiling in
fact it was 60% higher than the next
best contender but that that means that
it provides accuracy in identification
and speed
as well another independent validation
was with the FDA where we received a
highest score for correct identification
of species and also of strain video the
Kosmos ID is an apple in the cloud and
it's very easy to use
very very fast really within minutes
once we have the sequence and you can
try it out for free or by going to app
dot cosmos I be calm it's a very very
user friendly cloud portal and the
output is everything from bar charts to
Crona to a principal component analysis
and heat maps if it's a already the
output is provided directly let's see
let's turn now to some case studies
because my most close to me
my interest is water in environmental
safety so very quickly we've been
analyzing with Orange County Water
District in California the capability of
analyzing water that comes in from the
sewage park because of the drought in
California 50% of the water used in
Orange County drinking water treatment
plant comes from a sewage plant so we
test the water as it comes in we test
after it goes through micro filtration
reverse osmosis and we find that indeed
the influent water is loaded with
microorganisms including potential
pathogens and pathogens bacteria viruses
fungal and even occasionally a
Cryptosporidium but by the time it gets
through the Mike Miller pool filtration
what really is left over just the
typical water bacteria iron bacteria etc
that are non-pathogenic gets safe in
addition we find that antibiotic
resistance genes are markedly reduced
and we're able to show that to be in by
the time ago
those through reverse osmosis antibiotic
resistance genes are practically
non-existent a drug developed another
area where we are very interested in
doing a study with a group known as
synthetic biologics where they have been
developing a compound that can be given
along with an antibiotic so that the gut
at the end does not have the excess
antibiotic is destroyed by the
intervention the side effects of
antibiotics we know is to disrupt the
healthy microbiota I and then leads to
secondary infections but with this
treatment and this study was done in
pigs were able to show that at the top
this is seven days before the antibiotic
is given four days before the antibiotic
is given then the antibiotic is given
and you see that changes that occurs the
increase in other microorganisms the
decrease in the in the normal flora and
overgrowth so to speak but by the
treatment was with this synthetic test
sy and number level for this or this
compound you can see that when it is
given along with the antibiotic there is
a maintenance of the normal gut flora
this is a very important factor
another example is necrotizing cellular
fasciitis this was a case of of an
individual young woman who built herself
a zip line it broke she fell into the
water
gassed her lake and one of the rocks in
the water had a culminating ciliate
necrotizing fasciitis
they look for strep which is the common
organism but they instead isolated of
the four strains of era known as Hydra
flow three of which were clonal but when
the four strains were injected we found
in mice we found that only one strain
to the liver and spleen this was a very
interesting finding and we tested this
by being able to genetically engineer
the one strain to the bioluminescent
encana myosin resistance and we repeated
the experiment and indeed it was a
kanamycin resistant luminescent organism
that went to the liver and spleen and to
make a long story short it turns out
that one strain produces a tissue
breakdown factor and that allows this
one strain that goes to the liver and
spleen to migrate due to the ultimate to
it to the liver and spleen now another
important use of metagenomics is
understanding how strains of mica
pathogens are transmitted and in this
study we wash with a team in Singapore
studying the micro biomes of house flies
they're localized and indeed what we're
able to show is that by looking at the
thorax the head the legs and wings the
stomach of the Flies now we can
determine well not big surprise that
flies have dirty feet but that is they
carry lots of Michel of ism's including
silica back to pylori and then by the
analysis we were able to show that in
fact genes of Helicobacter pylori are
[Music]
detected that are associated with
pathogenicity so this is a way of being
able to understand transmission of the
disease agent and its potential
pathogenicity and then clinical
Diagnostics is really where Michael the
microbiome really is I think has a great
opportunity to contribute to medicine
and that is because most of diseases are
poly microbial and the actual
causative agent for example of
hemorrhagic fever 20% are unknown
prosthetic joy infections in a 15% of
the noon and at least 10 or 15% if not
more a polymicrobial and similarly for
endocarditis
periodontal disease so in the study done
by the Mayo Clinic which we were not a
co-author they did the study and used
Cosmos ID bioinformatics and found that
the meta genomic analysis was much
higher sensitive than doing culture of a
sonic a fluid for diagnosing prosthetic
joint infections and the detection of
bacteria was much much higher and it was
determined that patients that received
preoperative anti microbials
shows that metagenomics is much much
better in detecting pathogens in those
patients that had been treated with
antibiotics now in determining gut
health is another factor we've done a
major study of which were now just
releasing I'm getting ready to publish
with our colleagues in Calcutta India
where they did standard tests for
bacteria that is culture cell culture
etc for bacteria parasites and viruses
and we carried out with a blinded DNA
sample from the same patients and we
were able to show what they could detect
the disease agent in the upper left we
were able to detect the disease agent
but very very often not just a single
Biblio coloring but also d coli
Salmonella Shigella etc and where they
were not able in the upper right to
detect the pathogen we were able to pick
up the pathogen in most cases a mixture
of anthro pathogenic ntral hemorrhage II
that is pathogenic e.coli but a surprise
was in the lower left you can see that
the pink area denotes that the healthy
individuals who
served as controls for the study carried
a larger number of pathogens and then
compared to the human microbiome the
lower-right which we downloaded from the
NIH database Westerners carry only very
small numbers of pathogens whereas in
comparison to the Indian population
another factor was that antibiotic
resistance is more highly prevalent in
the Indian population even they helped
healthy individuals carry antibiotic
resistance genes at a higher rate than
in question gun flora and that is
because of the abundance of antibiotics
and the ability to obtain antibiotics
without prescription in clinics but also
for street peddlers in Europe and in a
study across countries and cultures was
very revealing 600 samples from 10
countries we subjected to a common
analysis and here you can see what you
might want to say is the median that is
the common gut flora of countries but
when you analyze by individual countries
we find that we can show a very
significant difference country by
country of the gut microbiome certainly
related to culture diet and other
factors and so looking at these
different countries in this case the
pink is Japan the yel T orange E is the
US and the darker color is rural India
you might say well they're very
different but when you do a principal
component analysis of large numbers of
samples we find that healthy pretty much
cluster together but then when you
compare with crohn's disease samples in
the green you can determine a very
significant difference in the gut flora
but what is an important point to make
is that you can use this kind of
information
as a public health parameter for example
these are protests catheter and
potential pathogens parasites
for example Anton IVA which is in the
central for Tanzania you can see a
number of different protests present so
this can be used for tracking let's say
parasites as well as viruses and if I
miss I think it's important to point out
that when you look at any one thing in
nature it's all gets together and that's
certainly the case for the microbiome
we've been working in areas of pharma
clinical nutrition agriculture plant and
animal health skin microbiome because
cosmetics as well as food safety water
safety and health so I would recommend
that if you have any questions you can
use you can contact at the website and
you can go on to the cloud through an
app and be able to do a free analysis
and certainly there many publications
found them as I mentioned earlier we
were able to do fecal samples now
because we have such large numbers of
sample analyses that we've done over
30,000 we now can let 3 million reads do
shotgun sequencing provide this amount
of multiple microbial analysis for $99
the software is very easy to use and it
provides as I pointed out sunburst
chart that shows your data a bubble
chart it gives you relative abundance of
the various components a doughnut chart
that gives you microbial composition a
tree of relatedness that allows you to
determine relationships and by the way I
should have mentioned we do our analysis
by phylogenetic not taxonomic so that
makes it much more highly
and you can do diversity through d3d
principal component analysis as I showed
for some of the samples done just now
and then species richness by a boxplot
chart and even pig maps are able to be
able to in your output as well as
stacked bar chart at chart comparison so
my final point is don't spend time
creating basic outputs spend your time
interpreting your data because you can
get all of the analyses presented
through the cosmos ID bioinformatics I
thank you very much for your attention
I'm doing this this kind of presentation
because this is very exciting and it's
what I was spending all my time on these
days thank you and questions
you
thank you both for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar so if you
have a question you'd like to ask dr.
Cole wells or dr. furnish please do so
now if you haven't already done so or if
you have more questions use that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as add that we have time for
at the yes well I sure has many
questions that we have time for okay
let's get started with so many questions
um let's start with this one okay dr.
Cornish is training for automated
systems available yes we absolutely
offer training with assistance and as I
mentioned before the NGS methods are
mostly already programmed onto the
instrumentation and the feedback we get
from our customers it's actually when
when we have it labs where they're
graduate students that they pick it up
in a day and they can even program the
system in a gray because it's it's that
easy great thank you
now dr. Cole well shotgun sequencing
sounds great but what about cost and how
much does it cost to sequence and
annales analyze samples well as I said
four of the stool sample we've got it
down now to weaken with three million
reads we can get a very very good
analysis and that's for under $100 and
that's everything from extraction
library prep sequencing a violent ematic
analysis output and providing all of the
data in whatever in all the format or
whatever format that is desired
sequencing depends really on how how
deep you have to do the sequencing for
example when you're working with 3po
spinal fluid and you're looking
essentially for that proverbial needle
in the haystack then you have to do very
high sequencing 60 million 80 million
reads and that can be can be in the
range of about 200 that's at least
some 20 million reads I think would give
you a good good analysis and then that
would cost a couple hundred dollars to
three or four hundred dollars but but
we're even getting that down we're
working hard to standardize in and bring
the cost down to competition with 16s
okay dr. Harnish let's go back to you
what do you mean by sample numbers
matter
yes thank you for for that question as
you've already seen from dr. Cole's
presentation more and more samples are
taken into consideration in making in
generating meaningful outputs and also
building meaningful associations and you
see that if you go into this global
consortium that to be part of it you
have to run significant sample numbers
and you might want to store these
samples to collaborate with other labs
for example to get metagenomics analysis
or to get get proteomics analysis and if
you look at the mouth study which I
presented to you pretty rapidly through
the number of mice you have to use for
these studies again to get meaningful
results you pretty much come to high
sample numbers and if in addition you
want to apply for for funding the
publication's you see are really being
based on more and more sample numbers
and higher sample numbers which you also
the Condor samples which are
corresponding to that you might want to
store for follow-up studies with
follow-ups funding etc and that that's
basically what I meant by increasing
sample numbers which we see over the
years throughout publications
Thank You dr. colo let's go back over to
you I love the concept of strain level
resolution and I understand that 16's
can't give you strain
why is cosmic I'd be able to give you
strain and is that unique to cosmo
fighting well the reason is because we
have a such a powerful highly curated
database and also the informatics that
we have developed over the last decade
is really very very very powerful and I
think this is really a good question
because it's very important for pathogen
diagnosis in public health as I as I
mentioned in my talk if you're going to
detect e.coli you want to know whether
you've got over in five seven because
you have different output yeah you know
you'll treat the individual quite
differently and specific strains have
struck New Mutants
produce hemorrhagic damage in the
nearing brain and other tissues probably
in humans as well so and also
understanding the presence of Toxoplasma
gondii which is a protozoan parasite
we're able to detect that and the reason
for the better performance is mainly
because our database is parla
genetically organized that is we have
distinct clades that represent distinct
subspecies level like path of r0 bar and
also our database is highly curated
we've cleaned out human contaminant
whatever other DNA that may be present I
hope that answers the question because
it's a very good question
thank you dr. Hunnish we're going to
come back to you do you think it is
important to use a mock community during
the NGS analysis
and yes I actually do think so and
ideally what I was showing mixed dual
samples would give you all the way
through the workflow actually a picture
and control and I actually would use
their different mock communities you
communities you can use if you mix mix
tool you would address also the sample
extraction in your in your whole
workflow if you just use a DNA mock you
make community you're basically
throughout the traceability of the
workflow would compare from the library
preparation step on and you are missing
out on the extraction portion of it
ideally using both might be a good idea
to compare the results
thank you now we are getting so many
great questions coming in we have time
for just a few more I want to remind our
audience that those questions we did not
have time to answer today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration ok few more
dr. cohle's will come back to you how do
you curate and validate your databases
thanks s is done by a combination of a
manual curation as well as being able to
take from the literature the sequences
that are present that are better that
are available in being able then to do
determines the presence of contaminants
and so this is done we spent the last 10
years making sure that the sequences
that we've got in our database of free
of contaminations we use mostly publicly
available databases and the genomes from
various databases are we screen them
very very carefully for taxonomic
accuracy naming and consistencies like
train name and ID and iswas number and
and so forth because that that is one of
the reasons that identification by
taxonomy is not very effective or as
effective as the approach we take and we
screen for contaminated sequences like
vectors adapters primer sequences is
certainly human DNA sequences is done
redundant genomes are screened based
mainly on assembly statistics and you
know this is really critical because of
understanding whether you have
contamination from technician handling
or from the reagents is is very
important as I say we just we kind of
built our own little database on
frequently now met up with contaminants
from reagents yeah not a lot
handling I hope that answers the
question because the database is a very
popular tool
Thank You dr. Caldwell and we're going
to wrap with this final question and dr.
honish why is that validation and DNA
sequencing data by PCR never heard of
and so for the most part that certainly
exists and actually I don't know why
it's never heard of I've heard of it and
presentations for example in the context
of a researcher who was presenting on on
pages and and viruses which is the next
step after the bacterial microbiome
we're going out and actually picking
specific parts of a certain virus or
certain microbes which you find and then
amplifying and seeing in which other
areas the organism resides throughout
the world it is actually happening
there's also a big viral project where
they start off with deep sequencing
identify key viruses which haven't been
seen out there and PCR follow-up is done
on that so it does exist out there I
think we are the reason why it's hardly
ever heard of we're still in a big phase
of association studies looking at the
the whole context of of the microbiome
and then to be followed the viral and
pages
thank you very much and I'd like to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their great questions again
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration our final
poll will now appear on your screen we
appreciate your participation and your
feedback I'd like to thank dr. Rita
Colwell and dr. Cristian Harnish for
their time today and their excellent
presentations I would also like to thank
labyrinth and our sponsor Eppendorf for
sponsoring today's webinar for those of
you viewing live today this webcast will
be available for unlimited on-demand
viewing lab or alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day device
you